♪ ♪
>> Sean: SPORT STARTING TO
COME BACK, THANKFULLY, TO
AMERICA AND THE USC PRESIDENT
DANA WHITE INTENT ON MOVING
FORWARD WITH MAY 30TH A BAND.
HE HOST AN ARIZONA 100% IF THAT
GOES CANNOT HOLD IT.
AND JUST UNLOADS ON THE NEW YORK
TOILET PAPER TIMES.
AND A REPORTER THEREFORE A
MISLEADING ARTICLE.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION UFC
PRESIDENT ONE AND ONLY DANA
WHITE.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW BIG OF A
FAN I AM FOR THE UFC, DR. DON
STOMACH OCTAGON.
I TRAINED MY OWN WAY AND I’M
GLAD YOU WERE WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO OPEN UP AT
THE CROWD?
>> GOD TO COME I DON’T KNOW HOW
LONG THAT WILL BE.
IT WILL DEPEND ON TESTING.
IF THE LEVEL OF TESTING KEEPS
GOING UP.
THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
A TAB YOU WOULD LICK AND IT
WOULD TELL YOU IMMEDIATELY
WHETHER YOU HAD IT OR NOT.
I THINK IT WILL TAKE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BEFORE WE CAN BRING
FANS BACK.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW YOU SAID
SOMETHING, "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
INTERESTING YOU SAID, OH, THEY
HAVEN’T COVERED THIS SPORT EVER.
THEN THEY ARE ATTACKING YOU AND
THEN THEY GET THEIR CLICKS.
NOW THEY ARE DOING TWO STORIES A
WEEK?
YOU TOLD THEM, YOU KIND OF
UNLOADED F THIS GUY.
I DON’T CARE WHAT THEY THINK?
WHY SHOULD YOU CARE BY THE WAY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE WERE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT SOLUTIONS TO THE
PROBLEMS AND HOW DO YOU BRING
SPORTS BACK FAITHFULLY AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND ISSUE
EVERY WEEK.
WHEN WE WERE LEADING UP TO THESE
EVENTS, WE HAD SO MANY, YOU KNOW
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND SO MANY
OTHER MEDIA PEOPLE TRYING TO
SABOTAGE THE EVENT SO IT
COULDN’T HAPPEN.
I MEAN, THIS GUY FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" INTERVIEWED
THE PRESIDENT OF ESPN, JIMMY
BRETT TAURO FOR 45 MINUTES.
WASTED 45 MINUTES OF HIS TIME
AND NEVER USED ONE OF HIS
QUOTES.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WERE POSITIVE.
>> THAT FIGURES, RIGHT?
I THINK THEY HAVE THESE
TURNSTILES TO WALK THROUGH AND
TAKE PEOPLE’S TEMPERATURES.
I THINK THAT COULD BE PART OF
IT.
IF IT WAS A MATTER OF GOING TO A
UFC FIGHTER MAY BE EVEN OUTSIDE.
YOU CAN DO THAT IN A LOT OF
CITIES.
AND IF I HAD TO WEAR A MASK FOR
THE SAFETY OF OTHER PEOPLE COME
I WOULD SUCK IT UP BECAUSE THIS
ISN’T GOING TO LAST THAT LONG.
AT SOME POINT, THIS ALL ENDS.
>> IT IS CRAZY.
AND YOU GET DIFFERENT
INFORMATION FROM DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND DIFFERENT SOURCES.
WE ARE GOING TO END UP LIVING IN
A WORLD COME A SPORTING EVENT,
YOU HAVE TO SIGN A WAIVER TO GO
TO A SPORTING EVENT.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW THAT COVID 19
VIRUSES OUT THERE.
YOU KNOW, I WILL TAKE THE RISK
AND GO TO THE SPORTING EVENT.
I DON’T KNOW IF TEMPERATURES,
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE STATES
ARE BEING ABSOLUTELY CRAZY ABOUT
THIS THING.
I DON’T KNOW IF TEMPERATURES IS
GOING TO WORK EVERY STATE, BUT
IF THE TESTING KEEPS GETTING
BETTER, WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
IS, YOU KNOW, WE CAN HAVE
SOMETHING WE CAN FIGHT RIGHT
THERE THAT MOMENT IF YOU HAVE
COVID-19.
>> Sean: YOU CAN DO THAT WITH
ALL THE FIGHTERS, THE TRAINERS,
THE TICKET TAKERS, THAT YOU
COULD DEFINITELY DO.
ALL RIGHT, MY STAFF APPARENTLY
SENT YOU SOME OF MY TRAINING
VIDEOS.
I BEEN DOING THIS NOW SEVEN
YEARS.
I DO IT FOUR, FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
YOU ARE LAUGHING.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD SIGN IF YOU
ARE LAUGHING.
>> I’M NOT LAUGHING.
I’M SMILING.
I LOVE IT.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP WITH
KARATE OR TAE KWON DO AND THE
MARTIAL ARTS THAT PEOPLE TOOK
HIM WITH THIS IS THE NEW MARTIAL
ARTS PEOPLE ARE TRAINING AND ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
I THINK IT IS GREAT YOU ARE
DOING IT IN ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS YOU CAN DO FOR YOURSELF,
YOUR WIFE, YOUR KIDS COME I LOVE
IT.
>> Sean: IS A COMBINATION OF
BOXING, AND I DO A LOT OF
SITUATIONAL TRAINING.
OBVIOUSLY, SOME PEOPLE THINK IT
IS SHOCKING AND THEY HATE ME.
JUST IN CASE.
>> I HEAR YOU.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: BIG FAN.
CAN’T WAIT TO GO.